the grayscale bitcoin trust is the
largest bitcoin fund in the world and
what many people don't know is that even
though it has 20 billion dollars in
assets about 640 000 bitcoin or so it
actually is one of the main reasons why
bitcoin's price went from about 10 000
in october of 2020 to about 64 000 in
march of 2021 the reason is because the
public shares of that fund we're trading
at a premium to the amount of bitcoin
that's actually in the fund itself and
so naturally wall street investors and
many sophisticated financial folks
around the world they started to go and
try to arbitrage it take advantage and
exploit that premium well so many people
went ahead and actually were giving
money to grayscale in order to get that
approximately 20 premium or so that
eventually the premium collapsed and now
it's switched into a discount which of
course is a big problem if you're still
holding the shares so if we go ahead and
we take a look here the bitcoin holdings
of the grayscale bitcoin trust
skyrocketed from the second half of 2020
into the beginning of 2021 but once it
went ahead and it switched from a
premium to a discount they shut off all
new inflows and it's pretty much
flatlined since then if we take a look
at the actual premium and discount
graphic what we can see here is that at
one point the grayscale bitcoin trust
was trading at 35 even 40 premium
meaning the public shares were worth 40
more than the bitcoin in the fund but
now it's trading at a 30 discount
meaning that for every one dollar of
bitcoin in the fund the shares traded 70
cents not a good idea now of course the
grayscale team they don't want this to
happen they want to convert the
grayscale bitcoin trust into an etf
they've been lobbying the sec via
applications and conversation to go
ahead and be the first to convert that
20 billion biggest bitcoin fund in the
world into an etf now the sec has
approved etps in the united states but
their bitcoin futures etfs they're not
bitcoin spot etfs and so naturally as
part of the application process to
convert gbtc into an etf the sec asked
for public comments it's been thousands
of people have written in messages but
one of them recently this week has stood
out from everyone else robert whaley who
is the creator of the vix volatility
index back in the early 1990s he put
forward a multi-page letter to the sec
and he basically broke down an argument
that stated if you're willing to go
ahead and put forward and approve
bitcoin futures etfs then you should
definitely approve a bitcoin spot etf as
well his main argument broke down into
three key elements and that's what
ultimately led him to endorse the nyse
arca application the first thing is that
the index on which gbtc is priced on is
virtually a perfect substitute for the
index that underlies the return risk
exposure for the futures based etf that
the commission already approved his
second point is that the bitcoin spot
market is vastly deeper and more liquid
than the bitcoin futures market and
third the product structure is much more
transparent and well designed now here's
the deal i don't know what's gonna
happen and i know that the sec and the
administration there they have concerns
in the market and they haven't approved
a spot etf i also know that grayscale
and many other applicants want to
actually get the bitcoin spot etf into
the market one of the most compelling
data points i think grayscale put
forward is that if their conversion
occurs it will unlock about eight
billion dollars of economic value for
gbtc holders i hold bolt i have
obviously direct exposure to bitcoin i
also have gbtc exposure in a retirement
account and if i take a look at those
two assets it's been better to hold the
bitcoin than gbtc but what's very
interesting to me is that right now gbtc
is still trading at a 30 discount to nav
and so naturally if somebody was to go
in buy the shares and then wait until
the conversion occurs you would think
that the share price would go back up to
equal nav there's a reason why many
people aren't doing this yet obviously
wall street and the financial markets
are full of super sophisticated
intelligent people who are constantly
looking at opportunities like this and
so it makes you think if the smart money
isn't going ahead and buying this asset
if they don't price in the fact that
they think there's going to be
conversion maybe there won't be but
again nobody has a crystal ball and so
naturally this is going to be something
to watch over the next couple of months
grayscale and many other applicants many
other market participants will continue
to lobby the sec to try to go ahead and
get the application approved convert the
largest bitcoin fund in the world into a
spot etf will it happen i'm not sure
leave a comment on this video let me
know what you think and i'll go in and
i'll respond later but one of the things
that i do think is going to be very
interesting is once they approve one
they have to approve many of them and
likely that will lead to a catalyst of
interest in bitcoin bitcoin continues to
perform pretty well given the macro
environment even though it's down a lot
still over the last two years of the
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
bitcoin has outperformed stocks bonds
currencies and other commodities so
naturally if that continues into the
future many investors are going to say i
have to get off zero i have to get some
exposure i need to be where the safety
is where the utility is and that's
ultimately what grayscale and many other
spot etf applicants are betting on be
fascinating to watch can't wait to see
what happens